Clark County Commissioner is gearing up
to vote tomorrow on the ban of selling
dogs cats pigs and pet stores well this
comes as our local shelters continue to
have an influx of animals coming in
Victoria Saha joins us live in studio
this afternoon with how a local shelter
recently saw the harsh reality of what
over breeding can do to dogs Victoria on
a daily basis our local shelters have
hundreds of animals waiting to be
adopted and then you have pet stores
that sell puppies so cute it's hard to
resist taking one home but you all don't
always get to know exactly where those
puppies come from
when you go into a pet store it's
difficult to walk away without wanting
to cuddle with the puppy but those
puppies come with a huge price tag we do
literally have people come into the
shelter and will surrender the puppy and
show us the receipt from when they
purchased it a receipt that usually is
thousands of dollars and their health
could also come at a cost ahead of
Tuesday's County Commission meeting to
vote on an ordinance to ban the sale of
certain animals the Nevada SPCA had
puppies come in surrendered by a breeder
himself I think Rey is the reality of
what happens when people get too focused
on the money Ray a pure breed french
bulldog was born blind with fluid in his
brain two of his siblings were born
without any eyes a sad result of dogs
being highly inbred by backyard breeders
our belief that in puppy stores it's not
a transaction in the animal's best
interest it's a financial transaction
backyard breeders and puppy mills around
the country often look to pet stores for
their profits so many residents of Clark
County don't necessarily know where the
origin the source of origin of these
puppies from pet stores are coming from
which is why commissioner Michael naft
introduced the ordinance where we have
an overcrowding of animals and then
we're also allowing inhumane pet stores
to be able to bring in these animals
from other areas areas that have animals
living in terrible conditions before
they end up at a pet store near you
Frey's two siblings were born without
eyes had to be euthanized because of
their quality life would have suffered
Rey also isn't out of the woods just yet
and commissioner nav said he really
wanted to tackle this issue before any
new pet stores come up which might add
on to the overcrowding of animals we
have here in Clark County Christian well
Victoria and let me ask you this if this
issue does pass tomorrow what is next
for the stores that sell these animals
well there are currently 14 of those
stores commissioner Knapp believes
majority of them came from California
when they pushed a similar ban but they
will have one year to switch gears to
their business and only operate as a
grooming or a retail store Christian